Let's do some equations of lines
in point-slope form.
And this is different from y or
from slope-intercept form.
But they really are just two
different ways of writing the
same equation.
We'll see that with a
couple of examples.
And you might remember that
slope-intercept form were
equations of the form, y is
equal to mx plus b-- we did
this in the last video-- where
m is the slope, b is the
intercept, the y-intercept.
That's why it's called
slope-intercept.
You have the slope and
the intercept.
In point-slope form, it takes
the form y minus y1-- and I'll
tell you what y1 is in a
second-- is equal to m times x
minus x1, where the coordinate
x1, y1 is a point on the line.
That's why this is called
point-slope form.
Now, these are just two
different ways of writing the
exact same thing.
You can always algebraically
manipulate this to get that,
or algebraically manipulate
that to get that.
And I'll show you that with
a couple of examples.
But let's just do a few in
point-slope form, just to make
things concrete in your head.
So here we have a line that has
a slope of negative 1 over
10, so m is equal to
negative 1 over 10.
And it goes through the
point 10 comma 2.
So we can directly go
to point-slope form.
So let's get a point.
A point here is the
point 10 comma 2.
So we can immediately go to
point-slope form. y minus,
this is a y-value that's
on the line.
So y minus 2 is going to be
equal to the slope, negative 1
over 10 times x minus an
x-value, times x minus 10,
just like that.
And we're done.
We just put it in point-slope
form.
There's two things I want
to point out to you.
One, why this makes sense.
And I also want to show
you that this is
equivalent to that.
So the first thing is why
does this make sense?
Well, all this is saying, if you
divide both sides of this
equation by that right over
there, you get y2 over x minus
10 is equal to negative
1 over 10.
Or you get the change in y
between any point and 2, and
the point 2, over
the change in x.
So you get the change in y over
the change in x for any
point x, y on that line,
relative to the point 10 comma
2, is going to be negative
1 over 10.
This is just the definition
of your slope.
Hopefully I don't confuse
you there.
I'm just showing you that this
is just using the definition
of the slope to create the
equation of the line.
Now, the other thing I want
to show is that this is
completely equivalent to this.
We can just algebraically
manipulate this to get that.
And let's do that.
So this right here is the
answer to the problem.
But let's play around with
it algebraically to
get it in that form.
So if we get y minus 2 is equal
to-- let's distribute
the negative 1 over 10.
So it's negative 1 over 10 x,
and then negative 1 over 10
times negative 10 is plus 1.
Now we can add 2 to both
sides of this equation.
And you get y is equal to
negative 1 over 10 x plus 3.
So just algebraically
manipulating it, we were able
to put it into slope-intercept
form.
So these two things are
completely equivalent.
Let's do a couple more problems.
The line contains
the points 10 comma
12 and 5, 25.
So let's figure out the slope.
So the slope, which is equal to
change in y over change in
x, is equal to-- well, let's
just use this point first. So
let's say it's 12 minus
25 over 10 minus 5.
This is going to be equal to--
12 minus 25 is negative 13,
over 10 minus 5, which is 5.
So the slope here is
negative 13 over 5.
Let's put it in point-slope
form, the equation.
So it's going to be y minus--
let's use this point right
here-- y minus 25 is equal to
the slope negative 13 over 5
times x minus this point, 5.
We just knew that the point
5 comma 25 is on the line.
So y minus 25 is equal to the
slope, which we figured out,
times x minus 5.
And we're done.
That's all.
If you want, out of interest,
you could do the algebra to
put this into the
slope-intercept form, to the
mx plus b form, and see that
they are completely
equivalent.
Let's do another one.
So they gave us our slope.
It's 3/5, and the y-intercept
is negative 3.
So here, immediately, this would
be very easy to put it
in the slope-intercept form.
The equation of this line is y
is equal to the slope 3/5x,
plus the y-intercept, minus 3.
And we'd be done.
But how do you put this
into point-slope form?
Well, we know the slope.
We know that m is
equal to 3/5.
But do we know any points
on this line?
You need a point and a slope
to immediately put it into
point-slope form.
Well, we know one point.
We know the y-intercept.
The y-intercept is negative 3.
That means when x is equal to
0, y is equal to negative 3.
So our point is, the point
0, negative 3.
You could have tried to figure
out other points.
You could have said, oh,
when x is equal to 5,
y is equal to 0.
There's all sorts of things
you could've tried out.
But this one was just sitting
there for us.
The y-intercept is negative 3.
That means that the point 0,
minus 3 is on the line.
So let's write it in
point-slope form.
y minus this y-value, so y minus
negative 3, is equal to
the slope 3/5 times x minus
this x-value, this
x-coordinate, x minus 0.
And this is point-slope form.
This could be y plus 3 is equal
to 3/5 times-- we could
write times x minus 0.
If you really wanted to make it
look like point-slope form,
this would be point-slope form,
but it's kind of silly
to write x minus 0.
So you could just write y
plus 3 is equal to 3/5x.
It's not 100% clear that
you're in point-slope
form yet right now.
But I think you still need
to write x minus 0.
And obviously, to go from here
to there, you just have to
subtract 3 from both sides
and you'll get that.
So these are almost
equivalent.
I mean, they are equivalent in
terms of what they represent.
They're even almost equivalent
in how you write them.
You just have to subtract 3
from both sides of this
equation to get to that one.
Let's do another one.
Let's put this in point-slope
form.
They're giving us information.
They're giving it in the
form of x, f of x.
So in this situation, when
x is negative 7, f of
x is equal to 5.
And this coordinate, they're
telling us when x is equal to
3, f of x is equal
to negative 4.
So just like that, we can figure
out the slope first. So
the slope, which is equal change
in y over change in x.
So let's do this.
It's negative 4 minus 5, over
3 minus negative 7.
And this is going to be equal
to-- negative 4 minus 5 is
negative 9.
And then 3 minus negative 7,
that's the same thing as 3
plus 7, that's 10.
So slope is negative 9/10.
And so to put this
in point-slope
form is really easy.
It's just going to be y--
let's do it this way-- y
minus-- I'll color code it-- 3
is equal to-- I'll do this
back to the green color-- is
equal to the slope, is equal
to negative 9 over 10, times
this x minus this coordinate,
x minus negative 4.
Then we can close it.
So this is in point-slope
form.
We obviously can simplify this
negative a little bit.
We can rewrite it as y minus
3 is equal to negative 9/10
times x, plus 4.
And we are done.